[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
terror and look it's the new studio it's
all set up isn't it beautiful i really
really love it um the lighting is kind
of wonky at the moment i'll kind of fart
around with it and see what i can do um
i will say that um i did actually record
one more video
that is a flickers of fear i think was
midnight mate train
and i still recorded that like in the
old blank ass studio so that one is
going to be going up after this one so
don't be like confused because i'm just
i was trying to record as much as i
could like ahead of time and things get
out of order and you know it was this
big kind of [ __ ] as things
usually are but uh yeah so we're gonna
do a book review today in the new studio
and hopefully everything works out and
everything is all set up so the book
that we are talking about today listen
to this i must be hitting the big time
you guys because
i was approached by i believe it's
turner publishing who published this
book and uh they asked if i would like
an arc advanced reader's copy of this
particular book to read and i was like
hey free books i'm all about that [ __ ]
so they went ahead and sent it to me and
this book is called the son of abraham
by kathleen kaufman
so this was sent to me and it actually i
believe it's released on october 26th um
i've seen october 26th i've also seen
december 2021 but this is a you know
this is an arc like an advanced reader
copy so this is not the one that you
will be buying at the store will not
have that little thing on it i received
this book and uh you know decided i was
going to read it and review it now this
is very interesting because prior to
reading this book i was not aware that
this was the third book in a trilogy uh
the trilogy i believe is called uh
diabal i think i'm not sure i'm
pronouncing that right d-i-a-b-h-a-l
i think like that so there were two
books uh in this prior
prior to this and this is the third and
final one i would assume
that said um i didn't know that and i
didn't really have that much of a hard
time following this i think like after i
finished it i was kind of like they're
like oh it's the third one in a trilogy
and i was like oh well probably would
have helped to like read the other two
beforehand but i don't really think you
need to there are like some references
i'm assuming to stuff that happened in
the first two but
i found this a pretty fairly
straightforward standalone type of story
so hopefully you will find it that way
as well although like i said i would
recommend reading the the first two and
i probably will go back and read them as
well because i actually did like this uh
quite a bit
so basically this is
kind of like a post-apocalyptic
end of the world type deal so if you
like that kind of stuff then you'll
probably be really into this
so basically at the first part of the
book and i think the first part um for
me like the first little section was
probably
the least i don't know because it took
me a little bit to get into this book
because what it does at the beginning
is that essentially
there is
a massive
uh like domestic terrorist attack in los
angeles and there's apparently this cult
uh called the sons of abraham and it's
led by this dude named alan robinson
robertson robertson and uh he's known as
the son of abraham and so he's like the
head of this cult and they're apparently
trying to bring about the end of the
world um in some sort of uh fashion so
there's an attack in los angeles you
know and this is like 10 years before
most of the book
so at the beginning it kind of like
jumps back and forth
between it's kind of like little
vignettes of like all these random
people and i don't know like i said i
don't know if they're actually random or
if they were people that were referred
to like earlier on in the trilogy
because like i said i wasn't sure um i
didn't know that this was the third book
in a trilogy before i read this one so
you know so so it might just be that
these were characters that you know were
mentioned in the prior books and i just
didn't know who they were because to me
it just seemed like oh we're starting
and there's all these like random people
around los angeles and
they're um the the first thing that
happens is like they're saying oh well
basically los angeles is gonna be
leveled in like 15 minutes so everyone's
like there's this all this chaos like
everyone's trying to get out like in
research you know maybe we can get in a
plane and get far enough away like from
the blast radius because apparently
what's happened is that members of this
cult have planted these massive bombs
like underneath like various points in
the city that's basically just going to
level it and everything like within a
hundred miles so and there's no time to
get everybody out like by the time they
discovered it so the first part of the
book is basically going back and forth
to people in los angeles trying to get
the [ __ ] out of there and essentially
failing i don't think that's like a
spoiler alert because there's really no
way that they could get out
so after that it jumps ahead 10 years
and what basically has happened in the
interim um after this terrorist attack
which killed like hundreds of thousands
of people or like tens of thousands of
people in los angeles and basically like
flattened most of the city
and so what has happened in the meantime
is that alan robertson the head of the
cult has been caught and is in federal
prison and is sitting there awaiting
trial
so there's that whole thing going on
there's also his daughter esther who i
think is in her 20s
and she basically grew up in this cult
but really um didn't seem to know like
what her dad was capable of or what he
was thinking about or anything like that
so it's been 10 years uh he
essentially killed everyone like his
wife his other daughter uh his you know
everybody else in los angeles
essentially but he
warned esther for some reason and told
her hey get the hell out of dodge
because something bad's gonna happen and
but he didn't tell her what it was and
so she left so in the past 10 years
because so many people were killed in
this terrorist attack 10 years ago
esther has kind of been
she kind of went into a group home
because she was still a teenager at the
time she was like 15 or something and
then she's basically had to kind of like
change her identity because people found
out like later like the news media and
stuff like that found out that
you know alan robertson the head of this
cult he had a daughter and he warned her
ahead of time and she was the only
person that he warned so everyone was
kind of suspecting maybe she knew
something maybe she knew something was
going to go on and so they're all trans
so she was getting like all these death
threats like she was responsible for
like what her dad did even though she
was just a teenager and all this other
kind of stuff so essentially this is 10
years later and uh we have a newscaster
named cooper carlson which i think is
like really funny it's because it's kind
of like anderson cooper and tucker
carlson together i don't really know so
he's like this kind of like hard-hitting
news guy and he sort of was just kind of
like a local guy until the terrorist
attack from from los angeles 10 years
ago which kind of made him like a
national sensation because he was the
one that covered it uh he was the first
one on the scene and all this other
stuff so now he's like a national
celebrity essentially and he's kind of
like the guy that you go to like when
you want to cover like this big massive
horrible disaster
so he essentially also tracked down
esther robin robertson
the daughter of the cult leader and uh
so he was able to find her and score an
interview with her so very near to the
beginning of the book like i said the
first part of the book is kind of like
10 years ago and just kind of goes back
and forth to random people like getting
[ __ ] up in the terrorist attack and
then it jumps forward to
um cooper carlson interviewing esther
like on the news which is good because
it gives you kind of like a little bit
of a backstory like maybe if you you
know it kind of gives you an into the
story over the course of the story like
i said this hasn't even come out yet
this book um it's you know it doesn't
come out until october 26th i believe so
i don't want to spoil too much about it
but what the what the bulk of the book
is it's basically going back and there's
a bunch of other characters like you
know um auxiliary characters ancillary
characters whatever um but it's
basically focused on esther
and cooper carlson the news guy and also
alan robertson and what and him being in
prison and
him being maybe a little bit more than a
cult leader and maybe being able to pull
off some [ __ ] that they're not really
entirely sure like how he's able to pull
it off you know what i'm saying so
that's kind of all i'm gonna say about
that but so the rest of the book is
esther trying to figure out
where his next attack is because there's
um you know on the 10-year anniversary
there's like another attack which
maybe could be construed as a terrorist
attack but maybe also could be like a
natural disaster they're not really sure
and alan the son of abraham like has all
these followers who do things for him
and various other things so it's so it's
esther
basically trying to she's kind of her
and cooper are kind of um at odds at the
beginning because he just he seems to
think that maybe she knew something
about what her dad was up to and maybe
she's like clued in to what he's doing
and like maybe she's not telling the
absolute truth about everything so
they're kind of like at loggerheads at
the beginning but as the story goes on
and like [ __ ] gets worse and worse and
disasters start happening um they have
to kind of like work together to figure
out you know how are we going to
you know stop the next attack where is
the next attack going to be what's his
end game what's his plan uh we really
have to find out how we're gonna stop
this and so they kind of like start
working together and um then there's
kind of like
like i said i don't want to spoil too
much about it but i will say that this
not this is essentially like a cult
apocalyptic cult novel but
i will say that it's not
there is like um a supernatural sort of
element to it too so like i said let me
know if you read like the first two
in this uh in this trilogy because
honestly it's like i
i think that maybe like i enjoyed this
quite a bit um you know apocalyptic
fiction it's not my super favorite but i
actually really liked that it wasn't
just straightforward apocalyptic fiction
there was also like a mystical
supernatural type of element to the
whole thing too because i like [ __ ]
about cults like i like that kind of
stuff but i think that
i need to go back and read the first two
in this because even though this um i
didn't have any problem following this
like it stood alone but there were some
references back to
some other things like some things that
happened when esther was a kid like
before allen kind of like went off the
deep end and became this crazy cult
leader person and there's some stuff
going on like on the supernatural tip uh
with the kind of like the the mythology
behind everything and i feel like maybe
that was gone into a little bit more
like i'm not sure but i feel like maybe
that was gone into a little bit more
like in the last two books so i think i
would have gotten more
out of that aspect of it if i had read
those two if i had known that this was
like the third but you know i didn't
know i was just kind of like i got the
email and they were like hey you want
this free book and i was like sure okay
and so i read it and i was like oh that
was pretty good but then i realized oh
well it would probably help if i had
read that but as i said it's not you
don't need to have read the first two
books um but i think it would probably
be a richer experience if you did
because i suspect
that there's some references in here to
like the society
which i guess was kind of like what the
cult started like in the beginning when
esther was a kid there was a an incident
at a cul-de-sac like it was a big fire
where apparently like all these people
died so it was like this early disaster
and i feel like it's only mentioned a
couple times in here so that was
probably gone into like a lot more like
in the earlier books and maybe like i
said some of the mythology because like
i said there is kind of like a
supernatural
it almost seems like
i want to say it almost seems like a
celtic mythology kind of but i'm you
know i'm not entirely sure about that
but that's kind of what it seemed like
like from the names and everything but
yeah um honestly
read the first two books first uh but if
you don't want to i mean this is a
perfectly good uh book just a as a
standalone particularly if you like
stuff about cut like doomsday cults if
you like stuff about like i said sort of
celtic-y mythology a little bit and also
like big disaster [ __ ] because that's
pretty much a lot of this is just kind
of like this at this crisp like
action-packed
sort of just people getting [ __ ] up
like thousands of people getting [ __ ]
killed in horrible horrible ways like
bombings earthquakes like all kind of
[ __ ] like that so if you like like real
apocalyptic fiction you know just
thousands of people dying in terrible
ways you know end of the world [ __ ] then
you will probably really dig this um but
yeah like i said
i really appreciate uh turner publishing
for sending this to me it was actually
really fun a really fun enjoyable read
like i said i kind of wish i had read
the first two books in the series prior
to that but i will rectify that
situation and maybe like give this one a
reread too like after that happens so i
can see like how it all kind of fits
together but like i said this is
perfectly good stand-alone too if you
didn't read the first two so you know so
that will do it for this tomes of terror
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye